[Music]
this is one of the biggest humanitarian
aid operations in the world
at the u.n syria cross border aid center
in turkey's hatai province
freight trucks are loaded with critical
aid including food
medical supplies and shelter materials
but this may be one of their last
shipments to northern syria
what you see behind me is the last
delivery from the u.n to the north of
syria
through the years we've tried to provide
better conditions for the displaced
civilians
and lift their standards of living by
providing aid if this aid stops we will
return to zero
trucks have carried critical aid into
the region since 2014.
most of the four million people in
syria's northwest
including the 2.6 million internally
displaced
depend on humanitarian aid delivered
through the only u.n authorized border
crossing
babel hawa the aid is vital for millions
of people devastated by a decade of war
if we don't receive the aid we aren't
able to survive
can anyone survive without water and
food i lost my husband in the war and
i'm looking after seven kids
aid groups say last year the u.n funded
204 humanitarian programs
in northwest syria worth 300 million
dollars
if the cross-border aid mechanism is not
relieved
90 million dollars of funding could be
lost
but syrian president bashar al-assad's
main ally russia
is indicating it won't work to relieve
the program
after it expires on july 10.
moscow says the u.n aid should be
delivered to assad's government
in damascus
[Music]
the regime will use the aid as a weapon
against people in northern syria
if it's distributed through damascus
we've seen the regime act that way in
the past
and we demand the international
community will act
duan says some of syria's most
vulnerable people live in
italy province and the failure to extend
authorization for the delivery of aid to
them
will have devastating consequences
millions of people are scattered across
hundreds of similar camps
with limited access to water food
electricity and medical care
they say they're afraid of what could
happen
if the cross-border aid they so
desperately need
isn't renewed that fear is heightened by
the assad's government
continued attacks in southern idlib
forcing many more civilians to flee the
camps
like this where they may find help is no
longer
on the way resulter al jazeera idlib
syria